foreign
[Music]
cotton and I am the owner and operator
of Jar Advanced superheroes of New
Orleans my name is Sophia Giordano Scott
I'm the co-owner and business manager of
dryer event superheroes of New Orleans
today we're going to look at how to
clean out a Dusty dryer vent
the main thing that it's basically
conglomerated from the vent pipes is a
lot of either dead skin cells pet hair
children's glitter regular hair just
dust dryer detergent
anything that can stay and stick on our
clothes that can come off in the wash
the worst is always going to be any pet
clinics you're cleaning towels daily and
you're not just cleaning cleaning towels
but you're cleaning cleaning towels full
of hair which is usually thicker and
coarser and sometimes more oily than
human hair the metal brush not only
breaks it up but it kind of catches as
well so it caught all that hair and you
can see as I pull it out it's just
almost a whole dog that it seems like I
pull out it was literally just mounds of
hardened pet hair and lint inside all
the way to the exit and then that exit
had about four feet of bird's nest just
compacted at that end because there was
no vent covered on the end it was just
an open tube so it took us about two
hours to clean the vent an entirely get
everything out we scoped it with our
little camera about six times trying to
make sure we got every little piece out
of there
[Music]
as the lint just gets stuck in there and
it builds over time the Heat can't get
out so the heat just stays there and it
accumulates right there and it condenses
and that's actually how a fire will
start
part of our inspection when we first go
in is to make sure is this vent
connected within the wall we only use
these types of vents they are metal but
also flexible but they're the only type
of connection hose vents that can
actually contain a fire as opposed to
the foil vents if you look on the back
of your dryer most dryers will say don't
use a foil vent and most people just
don't read that warning we get behind
the dryer and we take the metal tube
that's behind the dryer and we take it
off and we inspect to make sure that uh
the inside is either dirty or clean
because you either want to clean it out
or replace it
the Second Step would be to put our rods
with the brushes into the wall with the
camera we can see inside the wall of
what's going on and customer can see as
well of either how dirty or how clean it
is you can definitely tell almost how
long it's been because if it's only been
like a year or two maybe like a little
or nothing at all but when we're getting
to like the three to five years or plus
you're getting literal mounds of stuff
that's coming out you know it's almost
like from a mole hill to a mountain of
stuff that you're getting out you're
like wow it gets really gross if it's if
it's 10 plus years
so after we inspected and see how dirty
it is then we take our brushes with our
rods so it goes inside the wall and our
drill basically just cleans everything
out
we call this the vent polisher brush it
has this metal teeth at the end so when
that goes through your vent that's going
to polish your vents as well as clean it
so it's going to make it even harder for
lint to stick in the future
when we take our heavy filter vacuum
cleaner we make sure that no dust gets
in the air for either us or the customer
to breathe in
Cleaning Solutions or chemicals just the
the brushes and the HEPA filter vacuum
cleaner really does the job
and then once all that's done and clean
we turn towards the inside of the dryers
we uh get all the lint that might be
stuck in there we uh go back we take our
aluminum tube here and we put everything
back from the wall to the dryer we do
use heat safe tape on all of our repairs
or connection hoses we do also use
clamps the reason why we use both is
because you want your dryer vent to be
able to be unhooked every year and
cleaned and we pushed the dryer back and
then we check under the lint trap we
definitely found a lot of weird stuff
coming from the dryers especially under
the lint wrap I've had one employee as
we were cleaning he pulled out a whole
silver chain I found money uh like five
dollars and a couple one dollar bills
and then of course we get the not so fun
stuff for eggs and wasp nests that's
usually towards the outside of the house
not like in the dryer itself
also storm damage whenever we have a bad
storm hurricane and something that's
impacting the vent or the roof comes off
or something you're probably going to
get water in your vent in which case you
need a professional to come and take
that out because it's going to be really
nasty water mixed in with all that lint
so we've had multiple customers tell us
I've been in this house for over 10
years I haven't even thought about
cleaning it out you know like why are my
clothes still wet a lot of times it's
not your dryer it's in fact that the
line is just clogged up with all the
lint and hair and everything the most
important thing to do with keeping up
your jar vent is definitely to get that
annual professional cleaning but in
addition to that cleaning your lint trap
whatever use is the biggest one
I would say the most satisfying is
leaving with the customers all happy and
smiling and knowing that they're safe
that their house is safe and that their
product is going to work as they wanted
to
[Music]